(Şarkı çalmaktadır)
Transcriber: Tolga Boran Alper
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Merhabalar.
Aslında ben konuşmama başlamadan önce
hepimize böyle derin bir nefes
almamızı isteyecektim.
Ama daha demin ki yaptığımız
meditasyondan sonra
buna pek ihtiyaç kalmadı.
Çünkü konuşmak istediğim şeyler aslında
hepimizin bir problemi, hepimizin derdi,
olması gereken şeyler normal zamanımızda
ama ne yazık ki
çoğu insan bunun
farkında değil.
O yüzden bu konuşma süresi boyunca
kendinize size soracağım soruları
bir de kendinize sorun.
Ama dürüst olun bu konuda yalan söylemeyin
çünkü yalan söyleseniz de
zaten hep kendimizi kandırmışız.
Zaten bu zamana kadar, ne değişecek ki?
O yüzden buna hassasiyetle dikkat edelim.
Hiç düşündünüz mü ?
Evrenin sayısız gizemini, sonsuzluğunu
varlığınızın derinliğiyle
hiç hasbihal ettiniz mi?
Selam verdiniz mi gökteki kuşa,
yıldızlara, aya, gökte uçan kuşun
özgürlüğünü sonsuza kanat çırpışını
kıskandınız mı hiç ?
Öyle tahmin ediyorum ki, hepimiz
hayatımızın bir anında bile olsak
düşünmüşüzdür, düşünmemek
imkansızdır hatta.
Peki ya kendinizi, insanları,
evreni hiç düşündünüz mü ?
Bu konuda ise ilk sorudaki kadar
cevap net olmayacaktır.
İşte asıl kaçırdığımız nokta da bu.
Biz, insanlar ve içimizdeki evren.
Carl Sagan Kozmos adlı kitabında
yerküremiz bugün tamamıyla
keşfedilmiş bulunuyor.
Ne yeni kıtalar ne de bilinmeyen toprak
parçaları vaat ediyor demiş.
Carl Sagan'ın bu sözünün gerçekliği
karşımızda beliriyor olsa bile, hakikat
bundan ibaret değildir sadece.
Asırlardır göz ardı ettiğimiz şey
ise bizi orada beklemektedir.
Kendimiz.
Aslında her birimiz
evrenin bir kopyasıyız,
hatta mini bir evren olduğumuzu büyük bir
içtenlikle ve her ne kadar sizi şaşırtsa
da bu gerçekliğin ne kadar
göz kamaştırıcı
olduğunu söyleyebilirim.
Lakin.
Kim bunun farkında?
Neredeyse hiçbirimiz, bırakın fark etmeyi,
varlık kavramının ne olduğundan bihaberiz.
Bu sebepten olsa gerek insanoğlunun
problemleri hiç tükenmedi.
Hatta yığılarak ilerlemeye devam ediyor.
Gelelim bugüne.
Ülkemizin değerli düşünürü
İoanna Kuçuradi,
yaşadığımız çağı şu sözlerle açıklamış:
İnsanların robotlaştırılmaya, robotların
da insanlaştırılmaya çalışıldığı bir
zamanda yaşıyoruz.
Bu sözü ilk fark ettiğimiz takdirde
bir düşündüğümüz irdelediğimiz
takdirde bu dünyadaki sistemin
bize dayattığı tekdüzeliği çok
sert bir şekilde hissetmemek
içten bile değil.
Ne acı bize.
Sizlere itiraf etmem gerekirse bu
konuşmayı hazırlarken, sizlere ne
diyeceğimi düşünürken hatta hepiniz
hayatınızın bir anında bile
olsa robotlaştınız.
Çünkü sistem sizden bunu istiyor.
Lakin hala bunu kabul edemiyorum.
Onca cevapsız soruların ardından zihnime
hala daha tarifi mümkün olmayan
sorular ekleniyor.
Nasıl olur da hali hazırda
kusursuz olan insan ırkının yerine
robotları koymaya çalışıyoruz?
Robotlar bizim gibi olabilecekler
mi gerçekten?
Her ne kadar kabul etmek istemesem de bu
çağda düşünen, hisseden, yaşadıklarıyla
beraber olan insan sistemi
sekteye uğratıyor.
Çünkü bu sistem sadece üretim ve tüketim
cenderesi arasında
öyle bir sıkışıp kalmış ki
biz insanlar o çıkış, o sisteme
bir çıkış yolu bulamıyoruz.
Buna bakacak olursak, o zaman sistemin
en büyük ayak bağı biziz.
Evet, ayak bağıyız.
Çünkü düşünerek, hissederek bir
şeylere karşı çıkıyoruz.
Ama neye?
Sadece bu işleyen sisteme mi?
Yoksa aynı zamanda bu isyanımız
evrene de bir tepki mi?
Bunun cevabını size bırakıyorum.
Dünyada 8 milyar insan var.
Düşünün 8 milyar keşfedilmeyi
bekleyen evren.
Ne kadar eşsiz değil mi?
Acaba başka bir yerde başka bir insan
şu an ne düşünüyor, ne hissediyor?
Siz ne hissediyorsunuz?
Ne yazık ki insanların dış görünüşü,
hakikati, dışardaki görünüşü hakikat
olarak ibaret olarak zannetmemizden
başka bir yanılsama değildir.
Bu konuda ise birine başvurmam gerekiyor.
Yüce bilge Mevlana demek istediklerimi
tek bir solukta ifade etmiş.
Gelin ona kulak verelim.
İnsanı gördüklerinden ibaret sayma.
Göremediklerinde ara.
Içidir hakikatini resmi,
dışı sadece bir manzara.
Sorabilirsiniz bana kozmos kelimesinden
nasıl buralara geldik diye.
Inanın ki tek bir kelime evreni kaplayan
majör bir sorunu tanımlamanın
başlangıcı imiş meğer.
Konuşmayı hazırlama sürecinde beni en çok
ne yaşama bağlıyor diye düşündüm.
Bu iki cendere arasında sıkışmış kalmış
bir sistem içerisinde ben beni ne yaşama
bağlıyor ki ben hala yaşamaya
devam ediyorum.
Hala daha mutlu olmak için, kendimi
gerçekleştirmek için çabalıyorum diye
düşündüğümde bir şey karşıma çıktı.
Beni şaşırtmadı bulduğum şey ama
konuştuğumda başka insanları şaşırttı.
Sizleri merak ediyorum; insanları bugün
nasıl olduğunuzu, ne hissettiğinizi,
insan kimmiş, neymiş.
Geçmişiyle şimdisiyle geleceğiyle.
Bu sorunun cevabını farkettiğimde ise
evren ayaklarımın altına serilmişti.
Bir kelime var ki.
Bana evreni keşfetmeme yardımcı oldu.
Nasılsın?
Benim için artık sıradan bir kelime değil.
″Nasılsın?″
Hadi gelin hep birlikte bir de bu
âna bir kulak verelim.
Yaz günüydü,
güneşin batışını ve denizin o eşsiz
manzarasını seyrediyordum.
Bir yandan yanıma bir hanımefendi geldi,
biraz da yaşını almıştı.
Bankta tek başıma oturuyordum.
Dedi, yanında oturabilir miyim?
Dedim, ″Tabii ki teyzeciğim″
kıramazdım sonuçta onu.
Sonra oturdu ve döndü
dedi ki ″nasılsın?″
Ben de her zamanki gibi o dediğiniz gibi
″iyiyim, iyi gidiyor″ şeklinde cevaplar
vermeye başladım.
Halbuki farkına varmamıştım o sorunun
ne kadar mühim olduğunu.
Hepimiz de zaten bunu yaşıyoruz.
Hayatımızın her anında.
″Nasılsın?″ diyorlar
″İyiyim, iyiyim.″
Başka hiç bir cevap yok.
Hiç kimse kötüyüm demiyor.
Hiç kimse ya da bugün böyle oldu,
bugün böyle yaşıyorum,
bugün böyle hissediyorum demiyor.
″Nasılsın?″
eşittir ″iyiyim″.
Aslında teyzecim de bu ikileme, bu
denkleme, bu paradoksa karşı çıkmam için
belki de karşıma çıkarılmıştı kim bilir.
Uzun zaman konuştuk yaşanmışlardan,
yaşanmamışlardan, yarım kalmışlardan.
En son.
Döndü, ayağa kalktı ve dedi ki:
″Bu güzel gülümsemeni hiç
bir zaman kaybetme yavrucuğum!″ dedi.
″Çünkü bu dünyada bırakacağın
tek şey yaptığın iyilikler ve
o sıcacık gülümseme ne olacak?″ dedi.
Öylece o güneşin batışı
gibi gözden kayboldu.
Ondan sonra ise kendime bir söz verdim.
Keşfedecek en büyük hazine insanlar.
Onlardan asla vazgeçmeyeceksin dedim.
Hem o teyzeye bir teşekkürdü bu, hem de
kendim için dünyaya başka bakma açısıydı.
Şimdiyse bir eleştiri yapmak gerek bence.
Her gün bir yerden bir yere giderken
insanlara bakıyorum, seyrediyorum
nasıllar, nasıl gözüküyorlar diye.
Hepsi dışarıdan bakılınca çok farklı
gözükse bile ortak noktaları var.
Hem de o kadar büyük ve ağır ki.
Hepsi yorgun, mutsuz ve bıkmışlar.
Gelin hep birlikte içimize dönelim ve
asırlardır atalarımızın kendilerine
sordukları soruları bir de
biz kendimize soralım.
Belli ki bu insan ırkı ömrünü öylece
başıboş geçiremeyecek kadar akıllı,
yetkin ve donanımlı varlıklar.
Ben kimim?
Ben niye var oldum?
Evrende bulunmamın amacı ne?
Bu hengameye bu kafa karışıklığına, bütün
bir insanlığa bakılırsa
belli ki kaybolmuşuz.
Belki size yolunuzu gösteremem ama,
okuyacağım şu dizelerle
belki bir çıkış yolu
bulmaya yardımcı olurum.
Kim bilir?
Kader celladına,
sessiz uzat boynunu.
Acıma ne kendine,
ne de gelecek günlerine.
Yalnız bir düşünceye yum gözlerini.
Son darbe inmeden evvel.
En son anda.
Bir çiçek, bir kuş, bir tebessüm ol
düşüncen kurtarsın seni senden.
Bil, biraz sonra ebediyen senindir.
Senden uzak olan her şey.
Derin bir boşlukta bekleyen sayısız insan.
Seni duyuyoruz güzel insan.
Sen de duy bizim sesimizi.
Seni çıkaracağız o dipsiz kuyudan.
Sakın ümidini kaybetme.
İnanıyorum ki ümitsizlik, yokluk dolu o
kuyudan, o kapkaranlık kuyudan son insanı
çıkardığımızda gökyüzü bambaşka
bir anlam kazanacak.
O geceleri hayallerimizi süsleyen
pasparlak yıldızlar
belki bizim olacak.
Belki kutup yıldızı o zaman
başka bir anlam kazanacak.
Kim bilir?
Bakın.
İki evren nasıl buluşuverdi bir anda.
Benimle geçirdiğiniz bu süre boyunca
belki Merkür’ü, Venüs’ü, Dünya’yı,
gezegenleri keşfedemediniz.
Belki aklınız,
diğer konuşmacıda, akşam ne giyeceğinizde
ne giyeceğiniz ne yiyeceğinizde.
Alın size kozmos.
Olmuş olan veya olacak olan her şey.
Karşınızda bulunmadan önce sizlere ne
diyeceğimi çok fazlasıyla düşündüm.
Bir çıkış yolu bulmaya çalıştım
belki uzun zaman.
Kozmos bu ne, bu kozmos acaba bize neyi
ifade ediyor diye çok düşündüm.
En son,
aklıma bu geldi.
İnsan. Dedim ki başka kozmos yok ki.
Merkür’ü keşfediyoruz,
Venüs'ü keşfediyoruz, Mars'ı keşfediyoruz,
oralara keşifler yapıyoruz.
Ama en sonunda yine kim için, insanlık
için yapıyoruz bunu, kendimiz için.
İşte bunu farkettiğim anda ise sözcükler
dökülüverdi bir anda.
Vedalar ağırdır,
ancak her şeyin bir sonu var.
Size bu mini evreninden saygı
ve sevgiyle selamlıyor,
son olarak zihnimde ayrı bir yeri olan
yazarlardan biri ile zaman şairi ile
zamansız şairle, Ahmet Hamdi Tanpınarla
kalın sağlıcakla demek istiyorum.
″Ne içindeyim zamanın,
Ne büsbütün dışında″
″Yekpare geniş bir anın,
parçalanmaz akışında″
″Bir garip rüya rengiyle uyuşmuş gibi,
her şekil″
″Rüzgarda uçan tüy bile
benim kadar hafif değil.″
″Başım sükûtu öğüten″
″Uçsuz bucaksız bir değirmen
için muradına ermiş″
″Abasız,
postsuz bir derviş″
″Kökü bende bir sarmaşık
olmuş dünya sezmekteyim″
″Mavi masmavi
bir ışık″
″Ortasında yüzmekteyim.″
Kalın sağlıcakla.
(Alkış)